[Music]
[Music]
welcome to Google cloud on air live
webinars from Google cloud we are
hosting webinars daily and you are
watching the dev community a show where
Google cloud experts from the developer
community share perspectives about the
cloud ecosystem and what's trending my
name is Nathan Harvey and I'm a
developer advocate with Google cloud hi
I'm Nicole Fortran and I am the door
lead and today we are talking about the
accelerate 2019 state of DevOps report
so let's get started yeah let's
so the accelerate state of DevOps report
it's all about how do you become an
elite DevOps organization absolutely so
what we're going to talk about today is
this first DevOps is here to stay next
we'll look at some of the 2019
benchmarks we'll talk about how to
improve what works and what doesn't when
it comes to scaling and then we'll leave
you with a few takeaways and probably a
reading list
so first DevOps what is DevOps well
DevOps is a cultural and technical
movement focused on delivering value by
simultaneously improving velocity and
stability DevOps encourages cross team
collaboration shared incentives and
responsibilities and an environment that
celebrates learning that's kind of a lot
to decompose so yeah there's a lot to
get into so don't worry we're gonna be
talking about some of that today the
thing that I love talking about when we
say that it's here to stay is that it
has really crossed the chasm so what we
found this year is we've really kind of
validated what so many analysts have
been talking about for anyone who dug
into the 2018 report we found that 17%
of the respondents were elite performers
but if you take a look at this chart
here that's kind of a subset of the high
performers here's what we found that
subgroup broke out into their own group
it's 20% of our respondents this year so
that's pretty significant right they
almost tripled it really has crossed the
chasm we also see 23% of our group as
high performers 40
4% now our medium performers and 12% or
low performers now for any of you who
are kind of mapping this across here's
what we see
as I mentioned elite performers have
almost tripled that high performance
group has pulled across now medium
performers grew where did that growth
come from low performers shrunk so many
of them got better grew into high
performers some of our high performers
fell back into medium performers Nicole
why is that so we have a few theories in
many of the organizations I've worked
with what happens is some of them are
struggling with complexity a few of them
also are sitting back well sir you said
DevOps is cross the chasm so I've made
it I'm DevOps now I can stop that was
quite a journey
but now we've reached the destination
exactly and that's not the way
continuous improvement works you don't
just get to do a maturity model check it
off your box and be done we need to keep
improving particularly when we work in
things like technology where it's highly
complex so this is also interesting you
mentioned that the elite performers have
broken out so help me understand a
little bit more about what does that
mean from 2018 and as we move into 2019
I love that question so how do we even
measure this let's talk about this so
when we talk about DevOps and
performance it's important that we're
all speaking the same language so when
I'm doing research it means measurement
so some of you may have heard of four
key metrics this has become an industry
standard these are the four key metrics
we're talking about speed and stability
the speed metrics are deployment
frequency how often you're pushing code
lead time for changes how long it takes
to go from code commit to code running
in production and then to stability
metrics time to restore service how long
it takes code to come back up and change
fail rate
okay so first time to restore service
that's like when there's an incident or
an outage or something like exactly some
sort of service disruption how long does
it take us to get back to that yeah okay
that makes sense and then change fail
rate I mean I understand each of those
three
words I'm putting them together I don't
understand what you mean exactly and I'm
glad you asked that question
so changeval right and by the way you
can dig into the report we have lots of
words there but basically it's the
percentage of changes that fail but it's
not just an epic failure it's not when
your systems come all the way down it's
any type of code that you push into
production that requires any type of
attention so if it's any type of
instability any type of incident and
it's a percentage gotcha gotcha so it
doesn't necessarily mean that we had to
roll it back but it does mean that some
human had to take action on that
exactly exactly all right now the really
interesting thing and the really
important thing to note is that for six
years in a row now we've seen that speed
and stability all four of these metrics
go together they move in tandem they
cluster so that picture that you just
saw that's actually come that comes from
a cluster analysis so statistically oh
technical term I take them all these
four metrics I throw them in a hopper
and they see what happens how they group
and we have always seen that these four
group together in the past it's been
into three groups this year it fell into
four groups elite performers
statistically those four group together
and then we have kind of a gap and then
the four group together and then we have
a gap and then the four group together
in a gap and that's why we call them
different performance profiles like
elite high medium and low so the faster
you develop code the better stability is
the higher reliability you also have
what you think is Nicole so I get that
clustering here but yeah do you mean the
elite performers are fast or do you mean
that the elite performers are stable
they're both you don't have to sacrifice
speed for stability or stability for
speed now here's why when we think about
this if we're pushing code more often
we're pushing it in smaller batches
which means that when our code hits
production it's smaller let's think
about that in Reverse if I push code
less often yeah it batches up so I have
a bigger chunk of code so I have a
bigger chunk of code hitting production
which is a larger blast radius which
means it has a high
your likelihood of causing an incident
and when I do have an incident it takes
longer to bring my codebase back up and
it takes me longer to fix because it's
harder for me to debug
I see so to be more stable we have to
move faster and to be faster we have to
be more stable yeah and those things
move together and they move together oh
no that's really interesting but how do
you really find those elite performers
within that cluster with those four
numbers and and I do that statistically
with it's math that cluster analysis
math and stats now what does that look
like though so often people want to take
a look and understand where they are so
this is our benchmark and as I mentioned
elite performers are optimizing on all
four measures so we can see the elite
performers are pushing code multiple
times a day or on demand the lead time
for changes is less than a day they can
get that code all the way through the
pipeline time to restore service is less
than an hour and change fail rate is
between 0 and 15 percent it's usually
closer to 2 to 3 to 4 to 5% mmm now low
performers in contrast the deployment
frequency is between once per month and
once every six months lead time for
changes is between one month and six
months time to restore service is
between one week and one month and that
change fail rate take a look between 46
and 60% so that's about half the time I
have to intervene after I've pushed to
change out into production so think
about that so much of your time is spent
debugging your own code in production
putting out fires that's usually planned
for right so think about value creation
even whether it's in features or
building out new infrastructure right
this is the value of DevOps yeah and you
know when you talk about deployment
frequency in especially looking at that
an elite performer is you say multiple
deploys per day so what if I'm not doing
multiple two plays per day does that
mean I can't be an elite performer so
what it means is you you probably aren't
and we should be pushing towards that
now it does say on demand and multiple
deploys per day
on demand is important there because
it's the difference between a business
decision and a technical constraint so
if you can but you're just not we do see
some differences between you know in
retail you may push to a pre prod
environment but you aren't necessarily
pushing to like an app in the App Store
because like no users want to be
refreshing their apps every single hour
right right but again it's a business
decision and not a technical constraint
I see gotcha and it's important because
it's not just for features it can be for
compliance and regulatory changes it can
be for patches it can be for security it
enables so many things okay let's move
on there's so much to cover yeah so what
are these numbers actually look like
when we put them all together when we
put them together when we compare we see
their highest performers when we compare
to our lowest performers see 208 times
more frequent code deployments 106 times
faster lead time from commit to deploy
now what does that enable like I said
it's not just features its stability its
reliability its security so it's over
2,600 times faster recovery from
incidents it enables stability it's
seven times lower change fail rate I
mean these numbers are almost hard to
believe I know right but we've seen it
several years in a row now
how long is this report been running six
this is the 60s is the six and their
numbers I it sounds like they're
probably improving over time but the
they layout essentially the same yep
exactly that's incredible
now it's it's great that you can recover
fast and that you your change fail rate
is low and you're deploying fast but
what about availability availability is
super important and I'm glad you brought
this up because there's this saying but
I love that day one is short and day two
is long mm-hmm and and for those of you
unfamiliar with it it's that we can
build code we can make code we can make
software relatively quickly but we need
to maintain it for a really really long
time
that's what availability gets out it's
about the assertions and the promises
that we make and keep to our customers
and so availability is important we
started researching and measuring
availability in sim packs last year in
2018 we measured it again this year and
found that
no surprise it's really important and
it's important for a couple of reasons
in part it helps us predict
organizational performance better than
software delivery alone now
organizational performance is important
from a commercial standpoint and a
non-commercial standpoint there was like
Nicole what girl
that's my academic hat on commercial or
things like productivity revenue right
now non-commercial or things like
effectiveness and efficiency in customer
satisfaction so it just comes back to
delivering value okay great
so how do we think about availability
this is a good question yeah this is a
great question and availability is again
about that long tail and so I really
like to point people to Google's sre
practices and this is something that I
definitely know yes so Google's sre
practices can really help define
availability and the thing that I love
about the sre practices when we talk
about them is it always starts with the
customer so we're really thinking about
what is the customer journey look like
what does the customer expecting
availability if if your server is
running but your customer can't complete
the task that they wanted is your
service really available hmm probably
not so it all comes down to that
customer oriented focus we want to
understand what are our customers trying
to do with our services and to that end
that sre practices also introduce these
three different dynamics or dimensions
that you can look at the service level
indicators service level objectives and
service level agreements or SLA s so
let's just walk through them and I'm
gonna sort of count down in Reverse so
we'll go three two one we're gonna start
with service level indicators so a
service level level indicator is an
indicator that your service gives that
says hey are your customers happy or
your customers sad it's a good way to
sort of measure off time availability
latency things like this things that
matter to customers and then an
objective a service level objective is a
goal that we set around that metric so
we want to make sure that we're
available in percent of the time maybe
that's 99.9 percent of the time and
maybe our latency you know our service
is responding fast right when we expect
it to
then a service level agreement kind of
goes a step beyond that now a service
level agreement is typically an
arrangement that is made between
businesses and so when you miss your
service level agreement there are
usually consequences those consequences
usually are a refund to your customer
and I don't really know what business
you're in but I bet it's not giving your
customers money probably not probably
not we want to take the money from the
customers I mean we want to earn that
money obviously and I want to make her
customers happening absolutely and so
when we look at service level objectives
and service level indicators it's really
about what makes that customer happy
absolutely okay now this is some fun
stats this is some stats nerd time but I
love this because it's really really
interesting for a practitioner point of
view I'm an executive point of view from
an industry point of view so this year
we ran additional analysis well for the
last few years we've run additional
analyses and for years we found the
industry doesn't matter right if
anyone's ever heard me talk I always say
industry doesn't matter guess what for
the first time industry matters okay so
first industry doesn't matter now
industry matters no what you mean is
that industry can help us understand if
this organization is gonna be an elite
performer or a low performer or if
industry may have an impact I see right
so for an example for years people have
always said oh but I'm highly regulated
right right and I've always said ah
doesn't matter don't make excuses I mean
I love you all so don't make excuses so
we capture industry for for a dozen
industries this is just kind of a
representative sample uh-huh what we
have found let me guess let me guess my
guess is that the technology
organizations because their technology
organizations like they're going to be
the elite performers they're gonna be
the ones that really stand out everyone
know what retail and retail does
significantly better now we lay this out
in the report I love your shocked face
this is my favorite now what we found is
that for the last decade or so there's
been what has been termed
retail apocalypse it is unbelievably
competitive retailers have had to
embrace things like a be testing to
really understand what drives consumer
behavior right so that they know what to
offer consumers they've had unbelievably
slim margins so they have to embrace
efficiency they have to embrace
automation they also have to do things
like scaling for things like Black
Friday right so there is no question
about should we go to the cloud should
we embrace automation should we be doing
things like a bee testing they are
already there because if they don't they
have already closed down right and you
know with Google cloud we see eBay doing
things like this so they're using
machine learning models and they're
using artificial intelligence to really
help their customers find exactly what
they're looking for much faster making
that much more efficient transaction
both from the customer perspective and
from a base perspective yeah and so we
we caution that very many other
industries are probably following suit
pretty quickly yeah so another thing
that we found is that heavyweight
process heavyweight controls heavyweight
change approval boards slowly slow you
down slow us down and as we've mentioned
when you were slowed down that leads to
batching up of work which leads to
instability right so I mean a
heavyweight process and control over the
changes that go in that's there for
stability and protect us we have the
best of intentions but that can lead to
unintended consequences and in 2014 we
studied this for the first time and we
found that heavyweight change approvals
were negatively correlated with
stability and so this year we took a
more rigorous approach I wanted to
really design the center what we find is
it negatively predicts speed stability
for the same reason I talked about
before right when it you batch up
changes you have a larger blast radius
so it causes instability well but so in
my organization I'm an architect and I
have
a good eye I can see the entire
landscape and I understand how changes
are coming at the system and I I have a
better purview to decide whether or not
this is a safe change so how does how
does that slow us down so my favorite
joke is when I submit code review of ten
lines of code someone will approve well
they believe code it looks good so the
only thing that happens is it ends up
introducing delay however we do have
this great section showing with the cab
change approval board what the cab will
look like in the continuous delivery
paradigm and what it ends up looking
like our strategists and information
begins and what you can end up doing
instead is architecting okay and not
just being approvers got it so there's a
lot of good stuff in there oh that's
awesome
all right so we understand a little bit
about elite performers and what slows us
down how do we get better there's so
much to do here okay this year I'm so
excited I got a little excited we have
two models so in the past we've taken a
look at performance I've been talking a
little bit about software delivery
performance speed stability
organizational performance right we did
that again this year and added some new
stuff like we have in the past we also
took took a look at productivity so we
have two models two different research
models two different research models
that are predictive so keep that in mind
I'll show you two models we're gonna
hustle through two predictive research
month whoa
I know what is going on here in akola
okay I'm gonna teach you all how to read
a research model these are my favorite
okay
anytime you see a box this is a
construct okay so a construct helps us
understand what if what a thing is I'm
gonna call it a thing it's a construct
and it ends up helping us understand how
to measure something how to evaluate
something in ways that only measure the
thing don't measure anything else and
that everyone reads pretty much the same
way now I said the words thing of
there so let's look at something like
monitoring yeah so monitoring monitoring
is a box monitoring is a construct so
when we measure monitoring in a
scientifically academically rigorous way
I know that it's comprised of a few
things up monitoring across application
across infrastructure and it's used to
make business decisions okay when you
include monitoring that way that helps
you visualize the entire stack in order
for it to be predictive of continuous of
improving continuous delivery it needs
to capture all of those things and if
you word the questions in just the right
way that's the monitoring construct and
it measures monitoring and those
questions don't capture anything else
they don't capture loosely kept an
architecture they don't capture Trump
based development and everyone who reads
the survey reads all of those questions
about the same way gotcha so the
question is asked in such a way that I
know you're asking me about monitoring
and I understand what you mean when you
say monitoring and I know that's not
about Trump base development and there
are several questions there are lots of
them so I make sure that if you
misunderstand it so we asked lots of
questions by the way I love n8 all of
you who took the survey that's why there
are so many questions because then on
the off chance that I made a mistake or
the team made a mistake and we wrote a
question that wasn't clear I can catch
it when I do my stats foo and we toss it
okay so we've got these boxes we've got
these boxes and then I see a bunch of
arrows now we have arrows now the arrows
are predictive so this goes beyond just
correlation we have prediction so when I
said monitoring is predictive of
continuous delivery once I know I have
the boxes identified the constructs I
can look at the relationship between and
among the constructs so I know the types
of things that are predictive of
continuous delivery that helped me with
continuous delivery I know the things
that are predictive of sto software
delivery and operational performance now
occasionally you will also see a line
with an arrow with a minus next to it
right so you'll see that one continuous
delivery to burnout so continuous
delivery
is predictive of burnout of reducing
burnout that's what the minuses yes
so anytime you see an arrow without the
minus you can read it as drives impacts
predicts if it's a minus it negatively
impacts or it reduces okay that's how we
can read the model and you will notice
that oval that's our control variables
that's how I found out that industry
like retail was different okay
we also see enterprises different this
here for the first time only the size of
the company the size of the company is
different or leads to different results
leads to different results in a
significant way
interesting so now that we know how to
read it alright there's lots more in the
reports drill in a little let's drill
into something where do we want to start
ooh
cloud so cloud is a differentiator for
elite performance
okay now Nicole you said that when you
ask a question I understand what you
mean by the question yeah and you're
only asking about that young ya
construct okay so cloud Wow see you're
making it face though and and I get it
because I go to LA I talk to lots of
people I talk to a lot of developers I
talk to a lot of sad man's I talk to
lots of executives and you can ask five
people what they mean by cloud and I'm
gonna get like 13 answers sure because
it's the cloud yes so what what do you
mean so how do I get around this I get
around this by asking about how do you
define cloud as defined by NIST National
Institute of Standards and Technology
okay so how does NIST to find cloud five
key capabilities on-demand self-service
wait a minute is this public cloud or
private cloud it doesn't matter it's how
you architect it okay all right so you
said on-demand self-service was the
first one on demand self-service all
right can't put it behind a ticket the
requires human intervention okay so if I
need a resource let's say a compute
instance I the developer can provision
that on my own yeah without having to
open up a ticket hand it off to another
department wait for that to be processed
and then come back and now I have a VM
zero points okay the next one I see here
is bra
Network accent yep all right tell me
what that means can you access it from
lots of different types of devices
I see so if I'm on call and I need to
restore an incident and I'm happen to be
at dinner can I do that from my phone
yep interesting okay
resource pooling resource you know this
one yeah of course so I have the the
provider the cloud provider has a bunch
of resources and they pull them up and I
use what I want and then I give it back
and whatever and it's it's just there
for me yeah rapid elasticity bursting
like magic yes my favorite that's the
beauty of the cloud we can scale as our
customers would get more and more
customers coming in our infrastructure
just grows we serve all of those
requests everyone goes home happy right
am down oh right and down and out yes
elastic it goes both ways yes that's
something to remember I've seen many
many people that are newer to cloud that
are excited about the up capabilities or
the scale out capabilities and kind of
forget that the idea is also to scale it
back down yeah yeah well which relates
to measured thermos right so we want to
measure how much are we actually using
the cloud and we can get way different
insights into how we're utilizing a
service and importantly what my CFO
cares about how much money am i spending
on a service yep and I only pay for what
we use yeah absolutely
huh so this is what defines cloud so but
listen clouds been around for a long
time so basically everything I mean
shouldn't it just be a control like
obviously everyone's doing cloud in
theory right yeah
the challenge though like I said is that
everyone defines it differently so
that's why this research is so important
because when I go talk to organizations
when I go talk to people leading
transformations they're like but we did
the cloud I'm not getting benefits why
doesn't it work right
so we asked who's in the cloud and then
we asked these five questions turns out
only 29% of respondents who said they're
using the cloud actually meet all five
characteristics of cloud computing so if
you're in an organization that says
we're doing the
it's not working for me I'm not getting
the thing right this is what this is the
disconnect
so it requires execution I mean I bought
I mean I paid for a membership to like
my gym but I don't have a five mile a
five-minute mile yet mm-hmm I paid for a
membership do you have to do the work
I'm not saying it's necessarily simple
it requires work requires automation it
requires like architecting things yeah
but you got to do the book and I do both
an investment it sounds like yeah so
okay so clearly there's room to grow
with cloud but how does this line up
across like why do we care
elite performers low performers like
what does that it enables and it
accelerates this elite performers are 24
times more likely to have met all cloud
characteristics Wow
right because it's about enabling it's
about accelerating it's about speeding
things up it really helps so many things
go okay we've got some clear winds here
yeah it's clear that we need to get to
the cloud and really think about the
cloud is the whole thing right so we
have this idea of fast auto scaling and
as we talked about that's elasticity so
that's scaling up scaling down and and
the important thing there I think in
addition to fast is auto scaling yes
it doesn't require human intervention or
opening up a ticket hey I need to scale
up because we're about to have a bunch
of customers come in yep exactly
next we talked about cost visibility
cost visibility is really interesting so
we do have a section in the report
showing that because of the way the
cloud is architected and because of the
information it makes available it brings
that visibility back to those who are
building systems now when we're on Prem
it's just kind of a black box and so
there is no incentive to change the way
that we're engineering our systems if we
want to aggressively make our systems
more efficient why and we can't the
cloud enables us to do that in terms of
compute resources or cycles right right
interesting and then you also mentioned
security here is a clear win from cloud
I know a lot of people as they're just
getting into the cloud and certainly in
some industries there's some hesitancy
about going to the cloud because of
security so how is security
the wind from the clouds so there are so
many cloud providers that have already
gone through so many steps in so many
hoops to be a secure system that meets
so many compliance regulations from
information security to even physical
security that then you no longer have to
worry about you can allow your engineers
and your professionals to focus on
building code the right way and not have
to worry about securing your system and
and securing your buildings even right
right well that's great and of course
Google cloud has a ton of different
services for you that are available to
allow your engineers to focus on
building out the applications that your
customers care about it turns out your
customers don't actually care about the
infrastructure on which your
applications were on what they care
about is that those that infrastructure
is available sure they care about that
but they don't even care really about
the infrastructure it's about the
applications so Google cloud offers a
number of different resources that allow
you to focus exclusively on that
application and put some of those
infrastructure concerns to the side or
at least decrease your investment in
those infrastructure concerns so we have
tools for compute for machine learning
and artificial intelligence messaging
monitoring learning all of these things
are built into the cloud itself and when
we look at the cloud we we see a number
of different capabilities that are
really awesome one of them that I'm
super excited about right now is this
function or feature called cloud run
cloud run is this idea where we can take
serverless agility and use that with our
containerized applications so what does
that actually mean it means that our
developers can have a true server list
workflow and service approach to the
applications that they're building you
take your application you can Tanner
eyes it and then you hand it to cloud
run that's it you don't have to worry
about your infrastructure at all
cloud run will scale up as your users
use your service whereas your demand
requires cloud run will also scale all
the way down to zero and one of my
favorite parts about it and my CFO's is
you only pay for when the requests are
actually being processed
nice now that's really cool it's also a
great example of something else that
we've seen we're seeing lots of
organizations for example at the Broad
Institute they're cutting the cost of
research by adopting more and more of
the cloud features so maybe they started
off with just compute instances and over
time as they start really looking at the
capabilities that Google cloud provides
they're able to really slash the cost of
research so they go from maybe just a
compute instance down to some task
splitting some preemptable VMs and so
forth all the way through to the point
where they're now using algorithms to
tune how they're utilizing resources on
Google cloud platform so I love that
because that's a great example of
aligning incentives once you provide the
cloud to your developers they can really
tease apart only what they need they can
build their algorithms their
applications to really be super
efficient and just use what they need
right the other thing I love about it is
how it took an iterative approach right
yeah let's get this into the cloud and
now that it's in cloud we can start
thinking about how do we take more
advantage of the features that the cloud
really has to offer for us I love it and
I love it because it's the Broad
Institute and they're doing research
absolutely and the other thing that we
talk about a lot is shifting left so
what does what does it mean to shift
left Mikolka so yeah shifting left is
integrating features and functions
earlier into the tool chain and earlier
into the process because if we find it
late lead in a system late in the game
it's so hard and it's so expensive but
by expensive I just mean effort to
integrate all those changes the earlier
we can find it the earlier in the
feedback cycle right the better we can
deal with it and the higher the quality
is right and so we've learned about that
when it comes to building applications
we all know that fixing a bug in
production is much more expensive than
fixing a bug during design right right
and in the 2018 report we found that
elite performers could find security
features in dayz and fix them in days
where the low performance it took them
weeks to find and then weeks again to
remediate them right so when security is
an afterthought when we think about
security when we get into production
that it's already too late right and so
when we talk about
shifting left on security we're really
talking about taking those security
concerns and moving them to the left
side of our workflow or back to the code
the build portion of that workflow and
in fact using Google cloud when you take
your application and build it into a
container we have vulnerability scanning
that can look at that container and tell
you whether or not there are security
vulnerabilities known vulnerabilities
before your container before your code
gets anywhere near production we can
really improve that feedback cycle and
get it earlier in the process and so if
there's a vulnerability found we'll stop
you there and then the other thing that
we have is binary authorization
so you've packaged up your application
into a container you're ready to take
that container and run it in your GK gke
cluster or run it on kubernetes well how
do you know that that container that
you're about to run is actually the
container that you expect is it an
approved container that you're going to
run and so that's what binary
authorization can do for us it will look
at the binaries and say yes this is an
approved binary or no this cannot go to
production and we see this with
tremendous success over at Shopify so
every day 6000 built container images
are deployed securely into Shopify's
environment 6000 container images and
there were actually over 3,300 sorry 330
thousand images stored in Shopify's
container industry and I love that
because it shows how security can be
scalable yes absolutely and when we
shift it to the left it makes it all
that more scalable yeah exactly
now okay let's dig into a few more the
thing that's important here to think
about a holistic approach to CD right
because it is technology it is tooling
it's also process right so when we take
a look here we can see how all of these
things clear change process disaster
recovery testing continuous delivery in
this automation really drives our speed
stability and availability one thing
that's important here is we think about
useful integrated easy-to-use tools it
helps make CI CD accessible now on a
personal note I love this because some
this reaches all the way back to my
dissertation in my postdoc nice well
when you think about the integrated
experience look I'm a developer I want
to stay in the same contacts throughout
my day and it doesn't matter if I'm
writing code for the first time or
getting that code pushed off to
production and so with things like cloud
build which is integrated with github
you can actually get those signals all
without leaving the UI and the
experience that you're used to
so within github itself when I submit a
change
call build can pick up that change and
automatically build it I don't have to
switch context and think okay I've
submitted a change now I need to go
build the thing the thing gets built and
I get feedback directly in that same
interface that tells me how did that
build go
were there vulnerabilities in that build
and so forth now what we found is only
40% of our respondents are doing
disaster recovery testing annually
annually annually annual disaster
recovery testing is pretty important
because it helps us understand the state
or production systems and what's
necessary important to keep them running
so I love the idea of these dirt events
disaster recovery testing and before I
ever came to Google I kept hearing
stories about it so much so that we
included this quote from Kripa Krishnan
in the book yeah it's a great quote for
dirt style events to be successful an
organization first needs to accept
system and process failures as a means
of learning things will go wrong when
they do the focus needs to be on fixing
the error instead of reprimanding an
individual or team for a failure of
complex systems I love that that the
whole focus on learning is something
that really brings joy to my heart I
know it's great and the thing that I
love about this is that focuses not just
on improving the technology but also the
team surrounding it and the processes
surrounding it because there's so much
opportunity to make things better here
yes now I'm excited about this because
in the past
Google's project Aristotle has studied
this culture of psychological safety and
how it's so important for teams to be
able to do this now there was a little
bit of site commentary on the
tree saying of course Google would find
this because Google is this environment
where you have this amazing culture and
you don't have to worry about things and
they give you lunch and everyone passes
this amazingly difficult bar for
interview and there's no way that this
could hold in the rest of the world hmm
and so many thanks to the project
Aristotle team they shared their
measurement instrument with the Dora
research team this year and so we
studied this externally and this is what
we found we found that this same culture
of openness and shared purpose also
contributes to software development
delivery so it's it's slightly it's a
different outcome but but similar right
in the rest'll world
these same findings hold true I see him
and culture is more than just free lunch
absolutely so let's talk about some of
the culture that we do have at Google
that I think can apply in your
organization as well so the first is
that we let data guide us we use data to
make decisions that's super important
next we have collaboration and a shared
fate so when you think about DevOps how
do we align development and operations
we're collaborating together we're
sharing a fate or we're sharing
responsibilities next there's
transparency so we talked about this a
lot when we talked about cloud can you
get transparency into what is the
resource what are the resources costing
you how are those resources performing
and so forth that can that transparency
is important within our systems but when
I say systems I mean our systems not
just our systems but our systems right
so think about CPU of course but
finances and customer satisfaction yeah
transparency is important across all of
that and then lastly and every
organization can it take on this as part
of their culture a blameless postmortem
culture where when incidents happen and
they will happen what we do is we take
those incidents and those failures as
opportunities to learn and we do that
through a good blameless postmortem
culture okay
now let's dig into the second research
model as I said before anytime there's a
box that's a construct anytime there's
an arrow you can read it as prediction
if that arrow has a minus that means it
reduces so this year we took a look at
productivity now this is a special kind
of productivity it's not writing lines
of code it's not the number of bugs that
you kill it's when you hit that special
flow when you feel like you've done a
lot of good complex work for the day
now productivity is important because it
helps us feel like we've accomplished
work it helps us do a lot of like good
work for the day now what types of
things do we feel like contribute to
this we just talked about useful easy to
use tools this is great because that's
highly correlated to the CI CD work that
we just talked about also search also
things like reducing technical debt
we're gonna dig into a couple of these
yes I just talked about search yeah
let's start with search so I see here
that we have a one point seven three
times productivity improvement when
there's good internal search what do you
mean by internal search so internal
search encompasses a lot of things it's
like can I search my internal codebase
do I have a good internal set of
documentation do I have knowledge bases
do I have wiki's can I do I feel like I
can ask my colleagues mmm okay this is a
few things actually and then external
search might be things like Stack
Overflow or YouTube videos for that
matter places where developers and
operators go to learn more about the
technology that they're using or the
tools that they're using maybe the bug
that they've encountered the external
search for that one note that's
important to point out here is that
external search is going to be better if
you're using open source tools because
there will be a broad community from
which you can pull write for sure and
and who isn't using open source I will
say that low performers are the highest
users of a fully proprietary tool set
but read into it more we don't have time
to get into a new teaser okay also
technical debt drives reductions in
productivity so how can we reduce
technical debt this is super important
and we see this show up so many places
one thing that's interesting because we
all know that refactoring helps with
technical debt Martin Fowler wrote a
great book on it but what else can we do
in terms of smart investments in tooling
code maintainability how can we maintain
our code help our code bases be
searchable so that we
don't contribute to like tough
dependencies loosely coupled
architecture helps with this as well as
monitoring one thing that's interesting
you'll probably note these things also
show up in our other research model
smart investments in flexible extensible
viewable systems help reduce technical
debt so this can help with performance
and productivity absolutely great now
what else why do we care I mean I want
to be productive the other reason this
is important is that when I have a good
day at work when I feel like I hit that
great information that great flow yeah
and I can get a lot done I can solve
complex problems that lets me leave work
at work I can shut my head off I can
shut my brain off I can go home and it
helps reduce burnout oh that's great
yeah so next up quickly what works and
what doesn't so many people ask me how
can we scale my DevOps transformation
for sure I mean we've been talking about
the word DevOps for a decade now I know
I've seen organizations where a small
pocket of the organization will adopt
some of these practices and ideas and
and they do so to great success but how
do they get that to go across the entire
organization how do you actually swing
it out
so we asked all of our respondents what
they're doing what we're seeing and then
we did an additional analysis another
cluster analysis particularly among our
high and elite performers which was over
40% of our population so you can choose
what works best for you
here's what we see elite teams favored
structural solutions that build
community things like communities of
practice grassroots efforts and a couple
proof of concepts the reasons these are
good is because they build community so
they will be robust to things like reorg
or product changes okay so these are the
things that are good what are the things
that we should avoid these things are
not great training centers centers of
excellence are a Big Bang approach
now there were a couple notable training
centers that have gotten some press that
are pretty good the challenge or some of
these
and Centers of Excellence are that it
centers expertise in one place it
essentially creates another silo they
also take extensive resources it's
really really tough to figure out how to
get that to spread throughout an
organization and keep it sustainable
right they can work but you've got to
know what you're in for
well and I would suspect that a training
center works best when the learners that
come into that training center come in
with a problem of their own to solve as
opposed to come in to consume some
predefined curriculum yep now we do see
it show up in a handful of our high
performers but only about 9% now I will
mention Big Bang approach doesn't show
up among our highest performers really
at all we do see it among our low
performers which does make sense if you
need a hard reset you can do it but you
need to know that this needs to be a
multi-year approach and a multi-year
model right okay some of our key
takeaways the industry continues to
approve particularly among our highest
performers all right well that's great
so if the industry continues to improve
and we talked earlier about DevOps
across the chasm can we just stop
talking about that is it now just the
way it could be and honestly so many
companies I work with ask me that
I would say choose the word that
resonates for you in your organization
if it's DevOps if it's agile if it's
digital transformation if it's just
transformation use whatever's gonna work
for you and that's gonna help you with
both your commercial and your
non-commercial goals yep absolutely
Klout continues to be a differentiator
for the hyper for the elite performers
but remember you have to do it right
right so make those investments in those
five key areas that define what does it
mean to actually be using the cloud yep
productivity can drive performance and
work-life balance and reduce borne out
well just super important oh for sure
and also the bottom up or grass roots
along with communities of practice work
well for scaling out your DevOps
transformation yep now remember download
the report for so many more findings and
details you can find that cloud
google.com slash DevOps that's the 2019
accelerate state of DevOps
for all right well thank you so much for
tuning in today please visit cloud on
air for more content from google cloud
experts bye bye thanks
[Music]